foreign
quite honored to be here and it reminds
me of my days when I played in the U.S
junior clubs
feels great it feels great this is my
main Tournament of the year as soon as
the last one is over I start thinking
about the next year it's great feeling
uh all this
I am waiting to come to Saint Louis
because uh probably it's
the best conditions for the tournament
it's in Saint Louis it was a great
experience last year as well the first
time I played here as always it's great
so I I'm sure that this time
will be the same
I would like to thank everybody who made
this tournament possible and especially
of course rexing field it's great but
it's also nerve-wracking because this is
the most important Tournament of the
Year for me and I really want to do well
so
I'm gonna try to to Really Work Hard
actually I think I put more work into it
before because I don't want to be to be
too exhausted during the event but I'm
really looking forward to the games of
course I'm very excited it's very
excited just to be here to qualify it I
was really excited to get to be a senior
open last year it was really really
successful for me so I'm very happy to
be back in Saint Louis for a long time
it's uh became a second home so just
back home again it's honored always
honored to be here I think it's a dream
for every chess player to be here
because I always been saying that for
years no one no one else no Organization
no facilities no one else three chess
players as high as here
and we appreciate it and this is amazing
that's why for us every time if there is
a chance for us to qualify and play
Instant lawyers that's dream come true
this is the my the one picture in the
year they play in and so I look forward
to actually remembering how to play
chess it's uh it's wonderful to be here
it's amazing that you know the price
funders the first place I think is more
than the total price fund of the world
senior championship for example so it's
kind of amazing you know
so I mean I think it's it's a kudos to
Rex and and maybe feed they should work
on this in themselves uh but uh uh it's
always a joy to see old friends and to
play some good chess and to be you know
treated like royalty here so I enjoy it
a lot
[Music]
thank you